while u.s soldiers remain outside
ukraine ready to defend nato allies
more american military equipment is
coming in the u.s has pledged another
400 million dollars in military and
humanitarian aid to help ukraine fight
for its survival we are grateful for
everything that is there already and
that is about to come and we need more
because we are defending the our country
against a very strong enemy u.s
president joe biden has asked congress
for an additional 6 billion dollars for
ukraine most for its military the white
house is dismissing russian president
vladimir putin's threat that he has put
his nuclear forces on alert as the west
continues to aid ukraine this is really
a pattern that we've seen from president
putin through the course of this
conflict which is
manufacturing threats that don't exist
in order to justify further aggression
president biden is re-emphasizing that
american troops cannot enter this war
without creating further historic
escalation you have two options
start a third world war
go to war with russia physically
or two
make sure that
a country that acts so contrary to
international law ends up paying a price
for having done it along with severe
economic sanctions from the u.s canada
and the european union big business is
beginning to act google is now blocking
russia from monetizing state media on
its platforms including apps and youtube
and a handful of airlines will no longer
fly into russia delta suspending its
partnership with russia's aeroflot
while others are protesting in a
different way dumping russian vodka from
bars and restaurants like in canada evil
pie is going to be offering five dollar
f putin
shots of ukrainian vodka and all
proceeds are going to go to support
humanitarian efforts in ukraine more and
more businesses and individuals aiming
to hit russia where it hurts in protests
of this unprovoked war
jennifer johnson global news washington